welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and obi-wan kenobi takes us back to
the years following order 66 when many
assumed obi-wan and yoda were the only
members of the jedi order to survive the
emperor's purge but like the grains of
tatooine sand still tumbling around in
vader's suit i'm assuming these culti
refugees are coarse and rough and
irritating and get everywhere yeah if
you've consumed anything star wars
beyond the films you know that several
jedi survived order 66 and that at this
point in the star wars timeline there
may be as many as 200 jedi survivors
that number dwindling by the day yet
still many of whom were believed to have
died in the purge but as canon has been
revised over the years are now confirmed
to have lived some pretty interesting
years in exile and might have some
important roles to play ahead so let's
break down the key players proving that
our buddy ben ain't as alone as he
thinks in this fourth episode of our
series between the duels so who survived
order 66. of course we know obi-wan
survived otherwise we wouldn't have the
show he survived his attack from
commander cootie on uh and then
re-groped with yoda at the jedi temple
to see the aftermath of anakin's assault
with the 500 first even the young
killings later the two parted ways
obi-wan in exile to tatooine yoda in
exile to dagobah clone wars final season
showed ahsoka tano in maul's survival
from order 66 thanks to rex's ability to
resist his inhibitor chip 2016's ahsoka
novel by e.k johnston tracks ahsoka's
agrarian exile and run in with the
inquisitor the sixth brother before
ahsoka was able to rejoin bail organa to
become the rebel fulcrum agent of course
there was her survivor
who had been trained in secret at the
jedi temple for many years the kid is
the same age as darth vader and grogu
was snuck out of the temple by someone
presumably some jedi who knew that he
existed but that doesn't mean that that
jedi also survived the night now in
previous episodes of the series we
recapped the issues the 2017 darth vader
comics by charles soul explaining how
the jedi temple librarian jocasta knew
actually did survive that purge and
later backtracked to the temple to
retrieve a holocron of four sensitive
kids a chip that vader would later crush
after killing jocasta but still give
vader a key point of contention not just
between him and the other inquisitors
but between him and his emperor master
now if you look closely at these comics
there's a bunch of orbish names on
screen hinting at other jedi survivors
being targeted including case bernadoon
yoda we knew about him quinlan voss
kirak and phila jocasta new and ahsoka
tano quinlan voss awesome last name is a
longtime fan favorite jedi originally
just a background character with yellow
face paint and tatooine and phantom
minutes who was later given his own
backstory he was the master to ayla
sakura and he showed up in a number of
clone wars episodes his fate remains
unknown meanwhile kirakamila was a jedi
master from whom vader acquired the
kyber crystal for his new red lightsaber
kirik survived because he was living
alone in a jedi monastery on the moon of
aldaleem at the time of the purge now to
take a step back here perhaps the
creepiest thing about this ark of the
comics was the way that the emperor and
vader and the inquisitors really just
reclaimed the jedi temple the grand
inquisitor started reading books jocasta
had forbidden him to read just like he
owned the place meanwhile the emperor
would go on to turn this temple into his
private residence he hosted a bonfire of
jedi lightsabers on the front steps and
actually what sidious knew that the jedi
did not is that the base of this jedi
temple was actually a sith shrine left
there in the bedrock thousands of years
earlier when the jedi and sith were at
war over this turf so for millennia
embedded in the roots of the jedi
establishment was a sith cancer waiting
to strike now the game jedi fall in
order shows us the survival of the jedi
khao kastus as well as seer janda
mastered to the converted inquisitor
trilla suduri the second sister the game
also visits dathomir and introduces us
to the surviving jedi general taryn
malikos who used the last surviving
night sister marin to learn some dark
magic until marin got wise to his deceit
and buried malachos in the ground of
course in rebels we meet the surviving
jedi of kanan jairus who is once the
jedi padawan caleb doom we actually saw
that escape from order 66 and the
killing of his master deepa billaba on
magito in the first episode of the bad
match kanan of course would later go on
to work with the rebel alliance and
train for sensitive youth ezra bridger
the key dramatic relationship of that
series jedi master luminara and dooley
was alongside yoda at the battle of
kashyyyk and was able to survive but was
sometime later captured by the grand
inquisitor and her corpse was used to
lure kanan and ezra into a trap now most
of the members of the jedi high council
were slain but beyond yoda and obi-wan
there is some debate over the fates of
two other members mace windu and shakti
now windu canonically as of this taping
remains dead but samuel l jackson and
george lucas have toyed with the idea
that windu might have been able to
survive the fall and i've definitely
laid out several theories pitching mace
windu as a strong candidate at least for
the jedi master who rescued grogu shakti
was first suggested to have died back
during the battle in the opening act of
revenge of the sith but that was just in
a deleted scene then in a 2008 game the
force unleashed that suggested she
survived and was later killed on felucia
but various other materials have
suggested that she died at the hands of
vader in accordance with yoda's vision
of that incident in the season six
episode of clone wars called voices now
the 2017 comics also tracked down the
jedi pharyn bar on mon cala baron
managing to kill the inquisitor the
tenth brother but the guy was killed by
vader the y a novel force collector
explored the jedi knock med who left the
order before order 66 and had a daughter
with an unidentified woman he got in a
duel with the grand inquisitor but left
his family to protect them similar fate
occurred to the jedi master eth we
actually saw this guy on the jedi high
council in phantom menace and an attack
of the clones he appeared in a number of
clone wars episodes he ended up leaving
the order but still a devout force
follower he had a wife and a daughter
but the poor guy was eventually hunted
down by vader and the inquisitors and
killed and even worse his daughter was
kidnapped for the emperor's project
harvester baby snatching operation these
are the events that led to vader killing
those other two unid inquisitors and
this is a bit later in the overall run
when vader and the inquisitors had made
a lot more progress in their jedi
hunting and we actually see a list of
four more names of jedi survivors
actually five at the top of that list is
obi-wan kenobi but then we also see
coleman cassaj oppo rancisis selrock and
luos
was the jedi master who served the jedi
council during the invasion of naboo we
saw him in the background of phantom
minutes kassage served the council at
the end of the clone wars and oversaw
ahsoka's trial during clone wars both of
these pretty high profile badasses who
may still be alive in star wars canon
and by the way yeah those names many of
them actually coming from comics writers
spelled backwards like cell rocket lewis
is charles soul spelled backwards so
there you go that is over 20 known jedi
survivors of order 66 confirmed in canon
and really we should say in the years
following revenge of the sith's release
there were a lot of story lines that are
just now considered legends but still
any of which lucasfilm could adopt back
in a cannon and one of the more hopeful
undercurrents on this series is the way
obi-wan kenobi despite his grim exile is
able to keep that spark of hope alive
for any other jedi survivors that he may
meet and how any of these jedi survivors
continued existence drives vader and
inquisitors paranoid with rage yet while
still giving them a reason to exist at
all these inquisitors are about to learn
that one cannot eradicate all the jedi
like all cult ideologies they'll just
find a new island and a new generation
of impressionable youth to spread their
itch to if it sounded gross it's because
it is i want to thank you for joining us
for episode four of this between the
jewels series follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea boss follow the rockstars
and subscribe to rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you